Tim from Honolulu writes been a babbler  for about two years and my favorite  voice is the Buster Stallone we gets  progressively angrier and starts to lose  his [ __ ] I don't know if you've done  this yet but could you read a section of  dr. Seuss's classic green eggs and ham  and have an upset Sylvester Stallone be  really pissed off with the guy and tell  him he won't eat them says Tim from  Honolulu sure we can make that happen  that said I am I said I am I do the  latest and I am do you like green eggs  and ham I do not like them sam-i-am I do  not like green eggs am would you eat  them here or there  I would not eat them here or there I  would not even anywhere I do not like  green eggs and ham do I like them  sam-i-am  would you like to meet a house would you  like them with a mouse I do not like  them with a mouse I do the lady was a  lady there you go that's the best we're  getting really upset  [Applause]  [Music]  you